rarement finalement dans l'histoire de
la france on a eu un discours qui était
aussi coup et qui est une importance
finalement aussi décisive parce que
finalement c'est ça l'appel du 18 juin
ça a marqué l'histoire
l'honneur le bon sens
l'intérêt supérieur de la patrie
commandes à tous les français livre le
continuer le combat
alors déjà il ya un enjeu de légitimité
pour se remettre dans le contexte
arrighi occupés et surtout tout le monde
ne connaît pas forcément le général de
gaulle à 7 à cette époque ce qui est
intéressant dans l'appel du 18 juin
c'est qu'on a vraiment un exemple
d'efficacité c'est vraiment la réponse à
la question comment faire un texte qui
soit très très court mais qui soit
capable de marquer l'histoire parce que
finalement c'est ça le 18 juin ça a
marqué l'histoire on peut donc dire que
cet armistice
serait non seulement une capitulation
mais encore un asservissement
or au cou de prendre et n'accepte pas la
capitulation ni la servitude
jeudi l'honneur
car la france est engagée à ne déposer
les armes que
d'accord avec les alliés
tant que les alliés continuent la guerre
dans gouvernement n'a pas le droit de te
rendre à l'ennemi d'un point de vue de
la rhétorique pur si vous voulez l'appel
du 18 juin il est quand même assez
classique mais un classicisme qui
fonctionne très bien et c'est vrai que
rarement finalement dans l'histoire de
la france on a eu un discours qui était
aussi coup et qui est une importance
finalement aussi décisive donc c'est
aussi la preuve que parfois
l'efficacité ça peut vraiment valoir
toutes les longues phrases compliquées
du monde et que faire clair et concis
c'est vraiment très important
l'argumentation de de gaulle c'est
vraiment l'occasion de revoir les appels
persuasif classique c'est ce qu'on
appelle l'appel à l'action il est par
conséquent nécessaire
de groupe et partout où cela se peut une
porsche france est aussi grande que
possible
j'invite
tous les militaires français des armées
de terre de mer et de l'air
j'invite les ingénieurs et les ouvriers
français spécialiste de l'armement qui
se trouvent en territoire britannique
ou qui pourraient y parvenir
à se réunir à moi faire naître quelque
part ou même renaître l'espoir est donc
pour faire naître cet espoir de gaulle
se repose sur les deux ressorts que sont
le logos et le pathos le logos sait si
vous voulez tout ce qu'ils les éléments
rationnels pour convaincre de la
possibilité d'une victoire de gaulle par
exemple citer la cuy de l' empire
britannique et l'accès aussi à
l'industrie américaine
mails il nous reste un vaste empire
une plante attaque beaucoup d'or
il nous reste des alliés dont les
retours 38 morts et qui domine les
maires
il nous reste les gigantesques que
possibilité de l'industrie américaine
les mêmes conditions de la guerre ils
nous ont fait battre par famille l'avion
et prime il va
nous donner demain la victoire par vingt
mille phares et 20000 avions et donc à
partir de là de gaulle amène sa thèse
qu'on appelle la division en disant que
finalement puisque les causes de la
guerre et de la victoire allemande entre
guillemets sont sont identifiés puisque
c'est uniquement ça tout n'est pas perdu
idc véritablement d'essayer même en
utilisant quelque part ce qui nous a
fait perdre de le transformer en quelque
chose qui potentiellement pourrait nous
faire gagner c'est quelque chose qui
permet via sa narration
déjà fait renaître l'espoir très très
tôt en fait dans son discours cette
guerre est une guerre mondiale
nul ne peut prévoir
si les peuples qui sont neutres
aujourd'hui le restaurant demain même
les alliés de l'allemagne
resteront-ils toujours ses alliés
si les forces de la liberté triomphent
finalement de celle de la servitude
quel serait le destin d'une france qui
se ferait sous mille à l'ennemi
mais il va aussi utiliser le pathos
l'appel aux valeurs communes et de cette
manière en fait vous parvenez à toucher
le plus grand spectre d'auditoire
possible vous allez à la fois vous êtes
resté finalement au cerveau des gens
alors logique mais vous avez aussi vous
adresser à leur coeur et à leurs valeurs
l'honneur le bon sens
l'intérêt supérieur de la patrie
commandes à tous les parents très libre
de continuer le combat là où ils le
feront et comme ils pourront
ils essayent de se poser en figures
d'autorité bon c'est vrai qu'à une
question véritablement de poser une
légitimité s'il n'a pas cette légitimité
s'ils donnent pas cette envie aux gens
de le suivre bah finalement ça sert ça
sert à rien de continuer
développant les bras dans l'honneur et
dans l'indépendant
[Musique]